Hi everyone. In this lesson,
we're going to talk about Nanite and virtual shadow maps.
We're going to go over how those workflows allow you
to be able to use them with Lumen
and to efficiently get things the way that you need them.
We're going to break this up in a couple of videos.
So let's go ahead and get started.
So most people ask why Nanite?
Well, it's Unreal 5's virtualized geometry system
stored as hierarchical system
of smaller parts using triangles.
And it adds a geometric complexity
with less issues.
So what that means is the older versions
of using levels of detail in Unreal
were done via a specific piece of geometry
that was swapped out.
A lower medium and sometimes several mediums.
And then a high version when you're up close
would be put into engine so that when your camera
drew farther or near to the object,
it would swap out the appropriate piece.
That no longer is the case when using Nanite
and using Lumen and virtual shadow maps together
as a whole.
Nanite now uses triangles.
So it does it more on a more micro base
so that you can actually get the details still
just by swapping out the triangle pieces
for the particular section
where the camera's closest to it.
So you can really see that you're not swapping out
a whole item, but you're swapping out little pieces
almost like a puzzle giving you the highest fidelity
as quickly and as efficiently as possible.
So Nanite allows for higher visual fidelity
and works well with Lumen.
So you wanna pair that with Lumen
as much as you can in virtual shadow maps.
Outside of Lumen generating those shadow maps
like you're using the old school baking method
will take too long on a complicated mesh.
It can be used.
It really kind of depends on your scene,
but it's just, you just gotta be careful with it.
So it's better because you don't have to bake
to use it with Lumen in virtual shadow maps.
So you get the updates on the fly, no baking involved.
And you can get that high visual fidelity
for your models ready to go and on the fly
and get your updates as you go.
And it's really fantastic.
So virtual shadow maps are used for more realistic results.
We'll talk about in just a second.
So instance object count and draw calls
are less of a limitation now using Nanite.
Now instances are in the millions.
So auto LODs and streaming uses clusters of data
instead of object based, like I mentioned earlier.
So instead of swapping out the model pieces,
you're swapping out sections of the model
based on positioning of the camera.
It's pretty mind boggling and pretty awesome
the way it's able to do this
and the way that we have got it garnered
to be able to meet your needs.
It's fantastic.
So more visually accurate than displacement
and less shadow artifacts
because you will get those with displacement
if you're not careful.
Let's talk about that a bit.
So displacement is inaccurate with extreme shadowing changes
and light changes with higher displacement values
due to going beyond the object's bounds.
So anytime you're introducing displacement
and introducing that into an object,
you're going beyond the actual shape of the object
and you're trying to fool the eye
to make it look like that it has more detail
than it actually really does.
So bounds can be increased in the object.
You can do that to prevent any visual distortion,
but you still can get some inaccurate shadows.
So you can use that now with a model editing tools
inside the details of the model editor,
but you gotta be careful with it.
So just tread with caution.
It's better to keep it within the model itself.
So Nanite is great for a higher resolution model shadowing,
keeping accuracy, working with virtual shadow maps.
As you see right here, we have two lighting scenarios.
One is using the standard baked lighting
and a piece of geometry that is not Nanite.
And you can see we have the shadows here,
we have the geometry,
but you'll notice there isn't really
some nice, smooth, soft shadows going on,
some nice degrading of the shadow
away from its object of contact.
Over here, you can see it.
You can see a nice, harder shadow here,
and it starts to degrade realistically.
And you can see we have a higher poly model
converted to Nanite,
and you can see every single shingle
from the roof in here, and it's fantastic.
So it really just bump things up.
It can be used for ICV effects.
This can be used for linear workflows,
and again, also for games.
So you might ask again still,
what are some of the cool things overall
with Nanite when it comes to visual,
I mean, distortion?
I mean, can you still get some issues?
Like, can you still run into some problems with that?
Like, you know, I mean, there could be some hard corners.
Well, older versions of Nanite
used to rely on tangent space,
but now Nanite supports explicit tangents
in the data format and runtime.
So you're going to get more accurate shapes
within the model.
So that's another benefit
versus trying to do it via texture,
trying to do it via displacement.
We're doing it through the actual geometry,
which is way better.
So you can activate Nanite pretty easily in your system.
Let's go and jump into Unreal here,
and I'll show you how to turn it on,
and some things to keep in mind when working with it.
So here I have a simple scene with some Nanite geometry.
The one that I'm accessing
if you're following along for the class,
is you'll find that underneath,
if we go into our class folder,
and in our class folder,
you're going to see that there's a Nanite example
called Lumen Nanite.
Click on that and go ahead and click on the scene,
and you should be right as rain.
In the scene itself,
you'll see that we have several pieces of geometry,
and we also have this simple piece,
this simple rock here on the bottom.
I'm going to click on him for a moment.
So let's take a look at him in the content browser.
So to be able to turn anything into a Nanite object,
you just right click it,
and you want to go to Nanite,
and you can turn on Nanite here.
Once Nanite is active,
you can go and hit double click on the model itself,
and you can look at Nanite,
and be able to adjust things according to what you need.
Now we get into these a bit deeper
in our optimization course,
so we're not going to get into it too much here,
but you will notice there's enable Nanite support.
This used to have to be turned on in the past,
but now it automatically turns on
when you activate the object to become a Nanite object.
Down below you'll notice there's a max edge length factor.
If you're using spline,
if you have like maybe a spline construction tool,
and maybe you're making long pipes and wires and cables,
and you have them attached to that blueprint,
you may run into some visual issues that may occur
if you don't adjust this number here.
You can start off with 0.5 or even one.
If you run into issues where the,
as the camera moves around,
the level of detail shifts and becomes a very low poly.
If that happens,
just go ahead and go into your model details,
and under Nanite,
go ahead and go to your max edge length factor
and adjust this number if that occurs.
Also something to consider when working with Nanite,
is you want to make sure
that you're not combining large pieces of geometry
with each other inside of Unreal.
We'll talk about that a bit later
in our optimization course,
but what I mean by that,
if this is a Nanite object,
and this is intended also to be a Nanite object,
and you decided to merge them,
and even you can even convert that merge after the fact,
you kind of want to avoid it
because there becomes an issue of calculation
that isn't quite as efficient as we'd like for it to be.
So you want to keep them separate,
and Unreal's fine with that and works just great.
It allows it to isolate that piece of geometry,
apply the Nanite system to that object,
and keeping them individual.
That also helps you if you're going to modulate things.
One thing I want to mention
is you want to turn on virtual textures when you can.
They're not required to be used with Nanite,
but they are highly recommended,
specifically for games with large worlds.
That allows you to manage that overhead
so that things are going in the right direction.
So there's also a fallback tangent setting
in the Nanite static mesh editor.
This is a menu option
that provides more explicit control
over which tangent to reduce to for the fallback mesh,
relative error or percent triangles.
It helps choose which heuristic to use
when generating a static mesh.
Auto should work fine,
but the others are in play for more finite control
if the mesh is overly complicated
or has display issues and et cetera.
We dive deeper in these things
when we start tackling optimization.
To quickly check which objects you have
that are Nanite and not,
you can simply run this particular text here
by placing it inside of your content browser.
Let me show you briefly.
So inside of Unreal,
let's go ahead and go to our content browser,
content drawer,
and I'm going to go to the top here of my content
so it searches for everything.
And I'm going to slap that text in here.
Now this is going to show me,
it says Nanite enabled equal sign, equal sign and false.
It shows me everything that has not been converted
to a Nanite object.
I can simply shift select all of it if I wanted to,
right click and make that object become a Nanite object.
It's that simple.
This used to be in our debugger,
you'd find under tools,
but now we have it so you simply just can punch it
into your content browser
simply by using this particular text
and you should be fine and right as rain
to be able to check what is Nanite and what isn't.
That's it with this video.
In the next video,
we're going to be talking about virtual shadow maps
and do a quick overview on how it works
and some editing tips and tricks.
Thanks again.